on a reçu il ya deux trois semaines jean
pierre pernaut qui nous a dit que je
pouvais pas vous blairer d'où la
question de savoir ce que vous pensez de
lui et si à quelqu'un que vous ne pouvez
pas blairer aussi dans le milieu non moi
j'ai jamais il ya quelqu'un dont je dis
je peux pas le blairer parce que par
exemple jean pierre bouretz jean pierre
pernaut serait pas de reste que j'aime
plutôt bien jean-pierre dacheux bull
cheminots journée en revanche que gégé
mais pas les sujets qui traitait mais ça
c'est une question de goût mon goût à
moi c'est pas vraiment le goût est
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que tu
faisais à car c'est ce qu'il a dit c'est
un carton euros au trésor est très bien
il ya des gens qui aiment le journal de
13 heures de pernaut qui aimait ça tant
mieux pour eux et tant mieux pour
jean-pierre mais j'ai rien contre jean
pierre pernaut moi je n'aimais pas les
sujets abordés dans ce jeu là ça ne
m'intéressait pas je préfère un peu plus
de politique étrangère donc je préférais
le journal de france 2 voit mais c'est
une question goût ça c'est tout dans les
bois en revanche contrairement à lui je
ne me serais jamais permis de dire je ne
peux pas le blairer s'est passé m'a
vraiment fait ce qu'il a dit connais pas
on connaît pas une connaît pas elle
c'est sa femme qui dit ça mais il a dit
qu'il a dit alors allez plus que lui
alors c'est la traviata nicolas d'or il
a nommé au pyla du carrier oui ça je les
ai reçus tous les deux corps sont sains
choix c'est par là il vient goethe est
ingrat comme la 10éme ans mais je crois
pas je pense que tous les gens qui me
connaissent dans ce métier je crois être
l' inverse de la gratitude et lui pour
le coup il est ingrat parce que quand il
a fait de la promo pour sa pièce de
théâtre je n'ai reçu très amicalement et
très gentiment à plusieurs reprises aux
grosses têtes lui et sa compagne
donc je vois pas pourquoi il s'est mis à
balancer ça mais parce que j'ai pas les
mêmes idées politiques lui ça c'est
certain
c'est ça qu'ils dérangent et
d'intolérance de sa part mais pas de la
mienne